hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer a question
from one of our readers Lawrence who is
busy drafting the Constitution for a
nonprofit organization that is gonna
start very soon the primary objective of
the organization is to create a Center
for the community and Newton particular
and he's trying to organize career
exhibitions assists schools and
communities and getting motivational
speakers for events and taking part in
initiatives to alleviate illiteracy
unemployment and crime and he's try to
raise money and find donors and that's
his mission and he's asking for my
advice on how to help them get started
so Lawrence is great to have big
ambitions and goals for your
organization I think one of the best
things you can do is start small stay
focused
make one event make it a super success
and build on that success often we're
trying to do too many things at once
especially at the beginning
none of them end up going well so what
I've encouraged you to do is pick one
thing that you want to focus on so say
the motivational speaking get one word
of an inspirational speaker to come for
one event and make it a huge success
then you can use that momentum to start
doing other events and other activities
and build some momentum and credibility
for your new organization so in terms of
fundraising for the one event think
about the motivational speaker himself
or herself they might have connections
to help you raise the money for that
event they might be willing to donate
their time to it as well you might find
local business people or parents we're
willing to support this one initiative
you might be able to get the kids to go
up and help raise some money to bring
this figure to come in it's a lot easier
to focus everybody's efforts on one
specific cause that makes a lot of sense
then for an overarching
huge goal that people might not have a
connection to yet so I try to focus on
one thing at a time make it really
successful build a lot of momentum
credibility for organization you can
spin off into your bigger vision and
it's great to have a bigger vision I
don't want to limit you on that I think
for all entrepreneurs you want
where your where you want your
organization or company to be in 10 and
5 and 20 years down the road but start
with one thing at a time do it really
well build up momentum and credibility
and then use that success to leverage
and build your organization forward in
other directions so I hope that helps
Lawrence if you guys like the video
please give it a thumbs up below and I'd
also love to hear your thoughts and
feedback if you want to leave a comment
below the video and stay tuned to the
next episode
you